so today's but for we're gonna shout out
to hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba
salamander the Sally the Lomonaco lemon
ah oh [ __ ] just go off it when your
eyebrow raises to know if I'm saying it
right anyway
Sally have you ever seen Aldo Joan's
YouTube channel no he normally does
these things called weird trailers which
are very strange we're not gonna watch
one of those today we're gonna watch
this like fan trailer he made the Joker
origins for that Joaquin Phoenix one
that's coming in trailers before we hop
into this though guys you can false ally
on YouTube and also patron the de
shoutouts a boss gaming ro on our
patreon page his name is Lazar
Constantine that is a intimidating need
vampire name he's from Romania I have
just stereotype you she'd happen to be a
patronage acted day buddy this guy we
were talking he's have been a longtime
follower of the channel he lives all the
way in Romania his passion is unique he
wants to make games for Android and iOS
and he actually has this app available
on Amazon called the OWA news and the
product description goes as followed
tired of not having the ability ioaded
not having the ability to read news
offline with that Romania I'm totally
Russian and this is the app for you
forgive Romania sounds like works
offline and online I can read news
whenever you want that's a pretty cool
app I got to get it myself buddy boss
gaming ro it's got to tell you thanks so
much for being here you sound like a
sexy guy it's free who doesn't love a
good free app so go download it today
link in the description box and he also
has a channel called the smartphone
killer
so you just go check this guy um some
support anyway
let's hop on to this aldo jones video
sally headphones please
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
you had a bad day once am i right no I I
can tell
[Music]
we call the footage and
you know it's funny this reminds me of a
joke the editing man dude oh I wish that
was longer I have keep going I was
raised to dissect that man even though
that's not real footage of Joaquin
Phoenix as the Joker the effects that he
did on it to give the Joker effect makes
you go he's gonna be an amazing joke has
the perfect iconic look for it that
might not even be the look and the
design they go for but that's enough to
sell me on he's gonna be perfect for
this role because I have been a little
questionable about it I've been looking
forward to it but this has sold me a lot
more you still can't be Heath Ledger but
I feel like this is still just the
casting alone is a step up it but I'm
not mad at it you know I thought I'd be
mad at a new Joker movie but with him
I'm actually okay I'm really happy with
it and it's gonna be so different to I
feel like because it's gonna be this own
standalone film it'll be easier to go
let's not compare it to Jared Leto or
Heath Ledger or Jack Nicholson cuz it's
gonna be like its own thing which I
think will make it easier to
differentiate - do you think that it
could be in the running for an actual
Oscar or at least yes the big questions
s yeah
I mean Joaquin Phoenix he's a guy who's
is like destined to get an Oscar so I
wouldn't be surprised if he got
nominated for it I don't know sometimes
the context of comic book could make it
get kind of overshadowed but who knows I
mean he's a method actor so that would
be pretty sweet John do you know what
movie this is you know you can lose the
headphones I also got to say as a fan
trailer of those things really take
audio from different things I heard
stuff from our camels The Killing Joke
it is like slicing footage of other
Batman
stuff and then making it look like it
seamlessly from one movie I thought I
did a great job on that because this did
feel like a real trailer for something
there are times where it's like oh this
is obviously fan-made but then there are
other times you're like this could be a
real trailer you think this could be
DC's comeback you think so yeah I'm
excited for it
Aldo you have made this girl very happy
who looks like the Joker perfect a
Harley Quinn will tell you that that's
less offensive people like Harley Quinn
people think she's hot I don't I feel
like she's a freak
you guys got Sally's channel thanks Aldo
for letting us check out your video I
know you're always supportive of us
doing that I gotta bring Sally back for
one of your weird trailers because those
things are bizarre as hell but super fun
and you can subscribe to the reject
nation take care folks